here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show all right we're back on
the Internet what does the panel think
about Eric Cantor's plan for Congress to
work just 113 days in 2014 even less
than this year where the do-nothing is
to do nothing Congress's we produced the
least amount of legislation which
essentially is the Tea Party's goal
right they ran and continued to run on
dismantling government and and and treat
anyone who opposes them not as the
opposition but as the enemy and when
you're and when they don't agree with
you you're not just wrong you're a liar
right this course has just broken down
so badly that it's been working less
days yeah then you don't have to worry
about getting into you know you know
you're not gonna pass anything why even
pretend okay neil degrasse tyson do you
feel that the government should provide
an incentive for those who wish to
pursue an education in needed areas like
engineering science well don't we all
right well one way to provide an
incentive is to create goals that the
nation embarks upon that the very act of
pursuing those goals stimulates interest
in us all and when that happens you
don't need special programs to stimulate
interest when we were going to the moon
people climbed over each other to take
science and math and engineering in
school because this great Vista remain
undiscovered before us but but those I
think we call it stem right set in
science technology engineering and math
okay I think and those the best words
you can get out of those four letters
right here but I think I read a
statistic last year something like the
number of people with the you know there
were majors in I think it was the
Dramatic Arts was like two or three
times the number in stem and I think
what we have to do is convince a lot of
the people out there that they can't all
be stars can't all be mr. Rob Lowe here
you know and listen and then but then on
the other hand the New York Times
yesterday in the front page has a firm
bridge story how the humanity they can't
get enough humanities kids in the
humanities so because they all want to
want to be engineers and they all want
to work for Google
shift going on in progress and so the
humanities and universities are losing
their their student population base then
you have to start laying off faculty so
it's a big problem in the Universities
so they're trying to bring art back in
and they're calling it steam science
technology engineering art and math with
but they do that up fine it's a cute
word but they're forgetting why stem got
created as a concept to begin with
because stem forms the engines of the
21st century economy and if you want to
compete internationally you got to do
your stem otherwise what so it's not
just oh let's all just study everything
that's fine I don't have a problem with
that but don't believe that studying
everything directly consequence on your
economy as studying stem but keep in
mind this is also this is also tied into
the whole issue of immigration reform
because we are getting our lunch eaten
because we have no we are not educating
enough kids in science technology
engineering and math and so as a result
we are needing to import the talent from
other countries or we're educating them
here they give them the best and
brightest education and we don't have
the the immigration laws that are
allowing them to stay here so we send
them back to the country they came from
to compete against them right it makes
no sense and we've got to make sure
particularly for girls and
underrepresented minorities and I'm
sponsoring legislation that would create
some grant programs and President Obama
has proposed an initiative to make sure
that we can invest in science technology
Xtreme so the Republicans won't move on
any discussion that what you just talked
about about immigration to me seems like
no matter where you stand how could
anybody be against that
so I guess my questions how can you
decouple that from from the stuff that
divides the country on immigration that
really seems like we must ask yourself
that question every day how could people
be against this yes and every day they
are alright it's you're banging your
head against this just even though even
things that they they're not against you
mean it got 90 percent of people who are
in favor of background checks that
doesn't go anywhere
so you know it's well and although this
funk
Congress even - even things that they
previously were for if Obama touches it
I called his black tracking yeah they
will go against it just because anything
he touches on all of his nominations he
should be a political policy where he
does things he doesn't want to do yes
it's so bad yeah because we had actually
heard one ecology I mean Michelle Obama
recently came out for water drinking
more water you just to see if they
wouldn't come out against water mmm
the Tea Partiers Republicans have been
willing to harm the economy just to stop
the president throw any obstacle in his
path and shut the government down but
you jeopardized the economy bring us to
the brink of default simply because they
can't accept the fact that he was
elected president of the United States
his only claim to legitimacy elected
choice which they say is not legitimate
right but now we're gonna have a
probably a woman president next time
hopefully I mean I don't know who they
have that good probably defeat Hillary
and then I mean Louis that's the history
in this country that it was more
politically valuable to be a male of any
color than it was to be a woman so
because so so why against though black
men coming out of slavery a chief
political office before women did had
the vote before women did and so it's
been the fascinating tracking of the
history of this country with the Moody
in Lincoln with the with the debate Oh
in Congress over the Thirteenth
Amendment and that one scene where when
the suggestion is that we would actually
give women the franchise all the men in
the chamber go absolutely insane
including the Liberals Oh everybody
every single man in the room that was
absolutely unacceptable
so I was pretty sure you wouldn't have a
female president until you had a black
male president right yeah just based on
it but you must be eyeing further office
I mean I hope you do I mean you've
become one of the great rising stars of
the Democratic
I can't believe your career is gonna end
at the representative level I'm so
profound what's right Laura do I know
senator from Florida the president asked
me to do a full four-year term at the
DNC and I'm focused on making sure that
we move our party forward and that we
help Americans continue to understand
that the two very distinct paths that
are in front of us that we continue to
need to choose the moderate path that
strikes the balance and moves our
country forward I guess the economy
turned around focuses on the middle
class and working families you know what
a lot of the things that they won't
agree on are their old plans health care
the one we're arguing about so much this
is Bob Dole's old plan for Romney
tonight on these parties this is
Romney's plan this is a Republican
business oriented plan we should have
had a public option or even better
single-payer yeah but no I mean I'm just
saying the Democrats have moved to the
middle unfortunately the other people
have moved way over there so now the
middle is in the middle anymore no and
right now where Obama is is right around
where Reagan was right around where
Nixon was there he's no more left than
those those those Republicans hardly
never in socialist nor Leo no arolea
liberal no as Bob Dole said he could not
get right right anywhere in this
Republican Party and so Obama's right
around where Bob Dole I mean they're
very similar you know there's none of
them not a much of it than ever they say
oh he's the most radical president ever
right because there's such experts on
history 2011 what they mean is he's
black that's what's the most radical
thing about him in the summer of 2011
the last time the Tea Party hurdled us
towards economic disaster right our
credit rating downgraded Democrats and
President Obama supported 1.2 trillion
dollars in cuts only when we supported
both revenue and cuts to reduce the
deficit those were trillion dollars
worth of cuts that I spent my career
opposing and I voted yes because I knew
you couldn't default we couldn't not pay
our nation's bills right the Tea Party
continues with the Doug in my way or the
highway member the Republican primary
said why the highway
so you they wouldn't have highways cuz
the government built the highway yes
that's right
hi the Republican primaries my way for
the dirt road that won't happen next
door they asked everybody on the stage
all ten of them would you go for a nine
to one no I want you 1010 one-to-one was
the question ten to one and they know
not one of no you get ten ten to one you
get ten to one that's mine get the Ted
no yeah that's your false equivalency
that's right
go to all the Tea Partiers and remove
their LASIK surgery which was enabled to
happen safely and affordably because of
an algorithm that made the Space Shuttle
dock with the space they speaking of
surgeries never so funny why beyond the
cup candelabra Oh pictures really I mean
Harriet about result there he is I mean
what are you mad about
all right great we're way over time we
got to go thank you very much everybody
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10 past Bill and his guests your
questions right after the show at
hbo.com